[Música]
hola bienvenidos a cinco minutos con uno
de cada cinco niños en europa asegura
estar creciendo infeliz esto es lo que
arrojó un estudio de varias entidades
que trabajan por los derechos de la
niñez como unicef y save the children en
colaboración con la unión europea un
total de 10 mil niños entre 11 y 17 años
fueron consultados y uno de cada diez
manifestó sentir depresión o ansiedad
una de las consecuencias provocadas por
la pandemia de kobe 19 para analizar
este tema saludamos desde madrid a lucía
losoviz responsable de políticas locales
de infancia y participación en
unicef-españa lucía muy buenos días que
tan preocupante es esta cifra y qué
impacto ha tenido la pandemia de kobe 19
en esta tendencia
buenos días pues es una cifra que hay
que mirarla desde todos los ángulos si
nos está diciendo que el 20 por ciento
de los niños niñas manifiestan estar
constantemente tristes o que tienen un
conflicto emocional ya sea por depresión
y por ansiedad pero si este dato lo
vemos con un poquito más de detalle
vemos que se incrementa sobre todo en
aquellos grupos de niños y niñas que
pertenecen a grupos más vulnerables
estamos hablando de grupos de niños el
eje de iq que este número incrementa a
casi el 50% de los niños que manifiestan
esta tristeza y asimismo si vemos los
niños que tienen discapacidad o que son
niños migrantes estamos hablando que el
33 por ciento también dicen sufrir este
tipo de situación cuáles son esos
síntomas o comportamientos que nos
pueden dar un indicio de que nuestros
niños están sufriendo de ansiedad o
depresión
bueno el tema de la ansiedad y la
depresión creo que se puede manifestar
de diferentes ámbitos es verdad que el
estudio lo que nos estaba demostrando es
algunas de las causas que están
generando es o no la presión que tienen
los niños y niñas en el ámbito educativo
la poca perspectiva futuro lo que viene
ellos
cómo van a enfrentar los desafíos que
les van a enfrentar en el futuro es son
algo que le genera muchísimo estrés y
por supuesto en cuanto a los síntomas
eso tiene que ver también con sus
estados de ánimo con sus cambiantes no
su aislamiento muchas veces se
manifiesta en cuanto a sus relaciones
sociales que empiezan a estar más solos
o en algunos casos no tienen ganas de
hacer ninguna actividad ya sea
recreativa física o de otro índole que
podemos hacer los adultos por ejemplo
para trabajar en el manejo de las
emociones y cómo debemos reaccionar ante
estas situaciones
bueno lo primero yo creo que es ver y
escuchar a nuestros niños y niñas yo
creo que esta consulta lo que nos ha
puesto de manifiesto es lo importante
que es escuchar la voz y la opinión de
los niños y niñas solo ellos nos pueden
expresar realmente cómo se sienten y
cómo podemos buscar unas soluciones
eficaces y por lo tanto la apertura que
tenemos que tienen los adultos es de
escucharles de confiar de lo que nos
están diciendo y sobre todo tomar en
cuenta esas opiniones para generar
realmente cambios
de transformación real en sus propias
vidas entonces yo creo que el primer
paso es hablar con ellos tener un buen
diálogo y ser capaces de escuchar
realmente lo que nos están diciendo
lúcida cree usted que cifras como ésta
no sólo deberían llamar la atención de
los padres sino también de los gobiernos
es decir que trabajan en una política
integral frente a la niñez que le dé
prioridad a la salud mental de los
menores
y totalmente de acuerdo yo creo que este
informe que hemos hecho es histórico la
primera vez que el 10.000 chicos y
chicas de tanto el continente europeo
como de otros países han colaborado en
el diseño una política pública de la
unión europea es y estamos hablando que
van a diseñar la estrategia que estos
comentarios van a ayudar a la estrategia
de derechos de la infancia la unión
europea y que también van a ayudar a la
iniciativa y la garantía infantil que
pretende brindar este servicio a todos
los niños y niñas para garantizar el
cumplimiento de sus derechos y para
garantizar que no desarrollo y ahí la
salud mental es un tema fundamental el
kobe 19 no se ha puesto de manifiesto
que ya era un problema pero
lamentablemente lo ha agudizado y hoy
por hoy tenemos que tomar medidas tanto
las organizaciones como también los
tomadores de decisiones a nivel
gubernamental para que este servicio de
salud mental sea accesible y que todos
los niños y niñas que no necesitan
puedan tenerlo para garantizar como
decía antes el desarrollo pleno que es
fundamental para el futuro de ellos y de
ellas lucir a los suaves responsables de
políticas locales de infancia y
participación en unicef-españa muchas
gracias por acompañarnos en cinco
minutos o si a ustedes mucho
gracias por sintonizar nos continúen con
toda nuestra programación
[Música]